come up with a couple of gin and tonics
myself a couple didn't understand a
thing I know I wake up with Laura glove
next to the bed and my ass hurts I have
no idea what happened and my wife is to
blame and now we have baby it's cold
outside a nice love song a romantic song
about a man trying to woo a woman at a
party with a beautiful enjoyed history
in American culture they said it was two
sexually aggressive and they decided to
rewrite it thank you people from
Minnesota focusing on consent and rape
culture and it's as awful as you think
it would be let's listen you didn't have
the line about the pomegranate Lacroix
couldn't that's that's why I thought it
was a parody okay first off the song was
never about rape
let's think about this at least I can
say that I've tried I ought to say no no
no right she's talking about her parents
getting mad she's talking about trying
to play it hard to get being coy I ought
to say no no no they try to claim what's
in this drink automatically means oh and
all it means potentially I like this
drink what is this that's that's I'll
play the joy of playing hard-to-get with
the rape yeah yes I mean the song is not
about rape but it is about a man trying
to woo a woman and a woman trying to
play hard to get but it's it's it's the
dance that is love it's the dance of
romance right and let me tell you
something I ought to say no no no a
couple of drinks does that make it
easier does that lower inhibitions some
would say that's by design and some
would say that people enjoy that listen
let me tell you something I do that with
my wife I know I'm not raping her and
more often she does it to me you get a
couple of glasses of wine or cider and
my wife is always sudden really fun
she's a goodtime gal you see I'm just
saying what I'm talking about if there's
nothing
along with this if it's consensual and
at no point did anyone assume that this
wasn't consensual because this comes
from a time where a man would pursue a
woman she liked to be pursued
she liked the person to be a gentleman
she liked the man to make the drinks and
she didn't assume that he was a sexual
predator out to rape her and create a
new orifice a simpler era some might say
and do you have any idea how many
Americans across the country are guilty
of rape if it's a couple of drinks and
oh maybe I shouldn't one thing escalates
to another get on with a couple of gin
and tonics myself a couple dinner tonics
next thing I know I wake up with over
the loire glove next to the bed and my
ass hurts I have no idea what happened
and my wife is to blame not myself not
gay Jared's going she's going to call I
can see his face right now not what you
think
get your minds out of the gutter talking
light spanking it's sick and it's
twisted that you're having kids grow up
in a world left to listen everything go
oh this romance song maybe he's raping
her Michael Douglas and Romancing the
Stone that sexual assault Princess Bride
my gosh might as well be a prison gang
rape what are these people thinking they
see rape and everything they see the
world through a prism of rape like a
kaleidoscope of just women being raped
non-stop when they when they rotate it
it's like an LSD trip of rape if you
liked this video subscribe by clicking
the word subscribe if you don't there
are probably plenty of cats playing
piano that's probably more up your alley
I don't want to be pretentious but I'm
saying you're a stupid person